thanks for coming in today yeah
you're 18 right last I looked gorgeous
hey you must be cherry yeah hi so the
first question that I always ask
everyone is why do you want to do porn
you move really fast she's new she's hot
are you nervous sweetie actually I'm a
little bit nervous you should do of
girls clubs shoot we could do it
together
so even gotten naked yet you're already
getting on her and I've been nice and
Skyy I want to show you something it's
good to know your strengths and your
limitations I'm thinking about doing a
bad girl shoot I don't think you should
do it and action where's your boyfriend
get in here I don't know what happened
I'm sure he's gonna be here soon
you know my mom doesn't believe that you
exist I exist
sorry Emily don't worry you're the most
important thing on that set
mom you need to tell me if you need
money I can help temper the counting
firm with the funny dress code and fix
salary huh
I think it might be a bad person why do
you do what you do
the girl that you're waiting for to come
home does not exist
entertain us your work of art